مع انهيار
الهدنه المؤقته او انتهاء الهدنه المؤقته
واستئناف اسرائيل لعملياتها العسكريه
وقصفها
لقطاع غزه معنا الدكتور خليل الحيه نائب
رئيس حركه حماس في غزه ومسؤول مكتب
العلاقات العربيه والاسلاميه في الحركه
دكتور دكتور خليل مرحبا بك اذا انتهت
الهدنه وعاد القصف الاسرائيلي ما الذي جرى
في الساعات الاخيره
حتى فشلت جهود تمديد
الهدنه تحيه لك استاذ حسن ومشاهدي قناه
الجزيره ولشعب الفلسطيني الصابر
المحتسب الاحتلال الصهيوني كان يعد العده
ويخطط لاستئناف جرائمه وقتله وعدوانه
وحربه على الشعب الفلسطيني وعلى غزه
والاحتلال على ما يبدو حتى الان انه لم
يجد العالم ولا الاسره الدوليه ولا
الشعوب ما لم يجد منهم ما يردعه لوقف
عدوانه وبالامس احنا كنا لعند الصباح في
حوارات
واتصالات لتمديد الهدنه اي لهذا اليوم
ولايام
قادمه لكن الاحتلال الصهيوني كان يبيت
ويحضر لهذا العدوان الجديد بكل
اي عنف وبكل
ظلم الغريب ان الاحتلال الصهيوني من اول
امس احنا عرضنا عده مبادرات
وعده مقترحات للدخول في هدن
جديده الاستئناف تبادل الاسرى
وتبادل المحجوزين عندنا باسر الفلسطينيين
من
يوم من يوم الاربعاء ظهر الاربعاء قدمنا
مقترحا ل بادل
الاسرى لكبار السن ولفوق 60 سنه وغيرهم
الاحتلال الصهيوني لم يرد على هذا المقترح
حتى منتصف الليل وكان رده لا نريد الدخول
في حوارات اي شيء نريد ان ننهي
ملف النساء والاطفال للعلم استاذ حسن يسمع
الجميع ان الاحتلال الصهيوني طوال الفتره
كان يدعي انه ما هو موجود في غزه من
النساء والاطفال هم 87 انسان من من
الامهات والنساء والاطفال دون التاسعه عش
من عمره للعلم
اي احنا ما
تم تسليمه والافراج عنه من هذه الشريحه
لمساء الامس هو
85 امراه وطفل خلال هذه المده منهم اربعه
كانوا قبل تم الافراج عنهم قبل الفتره
الانسانيه بالاضافه الى ما تم الافراج عنه
من ال من الاجانب تايلنديين وغير
تايلنديين والاحتلال الصهيوني بالامس كان
يصر انه ما زال هناك عدد موجود وبدا يخلط
ما بين النساء والاطفال وبين الجنود
والمجندات
وسلم الوسطاء
بشكل يعني خبيث سلمه قائمه من الاسماء
جلها من المجندات
وهؤلاء اخذوا من قلب الدبابات الاسرائيل
وكانوا يحملون سلاحهم وكانوا يقاتلون
وقتلوا وواجهوا اي
من المقاومه التي واجهتهم في يوم 7 اكتوبر
ولذلك هو يحاول ان يتذاكى هنا وهناك مره
ويدعي لابد من هذا الحل هذه هذا جانب
ولذلك رفض هو التعاطي مع تبادل الاسرى
بيننا وبينهم
لفراج عن اسرى فلسطينيين من كبار السن
مقابل انه ان يتم الافراج عن ا رجال
من من كبار السن وما زاد اعمارهم 60 سنه
من المحتجزين في قطاع غزه هذا جانب الجانب
الاخر الذي رفضه الاحتلال
ايضا بجريمته النكراء ضد شعبنا عامه طالت
جرائمه وقصفه قتل بعض هؤلاء المحتجزين وهي
عائله بيبرس المراه وابنيها وكما علم ما
سمعتم بالامس ما زال موجود في يد المقاومه
زوج هذه العائله
وعرضنا المقترح ان يتم الافراج عن هذه
المراه وابنيها الذين قتلهم الاحتلال
بقصفه كما قتل ابناء شعبنا وان يخرج
الوالد ايضا ليشارك في دفن عائلتي التي
قتلها الاحتلال مقابل ما يوازيه من داخل
سجون الاحتلال طبعا و
و بظروف مختلفه ايضا الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
رفضت التعاطي مع هذا المقترح ليتم الافراج
عن جاثمين عائله بيبس وزوجها ايضا يعني
المستغرب انهم اصروا لابد من الافراج عن
عدد من هؤلاء قلنا هؤلاء في الغالب هم
مجندات
وايضا بحث اخواننا مع الفصائل ومع عوائلنا
في قطاع غزه لم يجدوا قلنا يمكن ان نفرج
عن اثنين من الاسرائيليين وامراه يوجد
عندها بعض المعلومات لكنهم لم يتحصلوا
عليها ايضا رفض ان يمدد الهدنه لهذا اليوم
حتى نسلم الاثنين والمراه التي وجدتها
المقاومه هذه ثلاث
اي مقترحات كنا جاهزين على ان ان ان
نتعاطى معها ايجابيه لكن الاحتلال كان
يراوغ ويرفض هذا الموضوع في دلاله واضحه
انه كان يعد العده ل استئناف عدوانه
واجرامه على الشعب الفلس الفلسطيني لكن
شعبا الفلسطيني ومقاومتنا لن يرفعوا له لا
الورود ولا اغصان الزيتون بل سيرفع في
وجهه صلابه وقوه وعزيمه وسترفع المقاومه
في وجهه كل ما تمتلك للدفاع عن شعبنا
الفلسطيني ان شاء الله طيب سنحاول ان يعني
ان نفهم اكثر مزيد من التفاصيل لكن قبل ان
ندخل في التفاصيل الان هل المسعى مستمر هل
هناك مقترحات جدي وخلا من اجل العوده الى
الهدنه احنا قلنا للوسطاء من قبل في وسط
الاسبوع والان نحن منفتحون على
اي لتبادل هؤلاء المحتجزين عنا من
المدنيين وصولا الى وقف اطلاق النار نحن
نريد وقف اطلاق النار لينتهي هذا العدوان
وهذا هي وهذه الحرب المجنونه على شعبنا
لكن الاحتلال ما زال مخططه ان يستمر القتل
والدمار والتدمير وهذه هي
بعهده المجتمع الدولي ولذلك الامريكان
بالامس قبيل كل عدوان جديد لابد ان ترى
وزير الخارجيه الامريكي والاداره
الامريكيه يمد هذا الكيان المجرم بكل
ادوات الحمايه السياسيه وغير ذلك ومن هنا
انا استغرب بالامس كان بلينك موجود عند
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي وكانه اطاه الضوء
الاخضر لاستئناف جوله جديده من من القتل
نحن قلنا اننا منفتحون على
هذه لننهي هذا الملف من عندنا لكن لابد ان
ان نصل الى مرحله ما كما تفعل كل الدول
وكل الكيانات وكل الحروب والنزاعات ما
يكون بين يد الاطراف من اسرى يتم تبادله
في نهايه الحرب ولكن لا يمكن انه تستمر في
انهاء هذا الملف ومن الصعوبه انهاء هذا
الملف في وقت الحرب والعدوان والقصف احنا
تجاوبنا مع ملف المدنيين من النساء
والاطفال لانه هذا في بعده الانساني
وبعده الاخلاقي وانتم
رايتم الحجم العمل الاخلاقي والانساني
الذي تمتعت به كتائبنا ومقاومون وعائلاتنا
الذين كانوا يستضيفون هؤلاء او كانوا
يحتجزون في بيوتهم طيب دكتور خليل كم
مازال لديكم من المدنيين الذين يمكن
ان تقبلوا ب اطلاق
سراحهم وفق طبعا من ضمن الهدنه ووفقا
للشروط السابقه كم
عددهم ليس لدي عدد محدد يمكن الافصاح عنه
لان هؤلاء
هم يعني شرائح ما زال موجود الرجال كبار
سن اي ما زال موجود الجنود الذين اخذوا من
الميدان متواجد بيد المقاومه الجنود الذين
تحت الاحتياط وكانوا يعني ما يعني
تحت التجنيد الاحتياطي او غير ذلك هذه
فئات متعدده موجوده بالاضافه الى الجثامين
جثامين
ال الاسرائيليين الذين قتلوا بسبب قصف
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي لقطاع غزه بما فيه من
فلسطينيين وغير فلسطينيين وهؤلاء اعداد
تحتاج الى حصر و وبحث بشكل كامل في ظروف
طبيعيه باعتقادي العدد بالضبط يعني لا لا
بد ان تتوفر ظروف طبيعيه للوصول له كاملا
وحصره وترتيبه ضمن قوائم محدده للوصول الى
عمليه تبادل كامله في كل فئه من الفئات
نعم لكن انا سالت ليس عن المجندات ولا
المجندين ولا العسكر انا سالت فقط عن
المدنيين الذي تنطبق عليه عليهم شروط
الهدنه كما مرت في الايام السابقه
فقط ليس لدي عدد محدد ام طيب ال انتم
منفتحون الان
على على مجموعه من المقترحات تختلف عما
كان في
السابق بلا شك كل شريحه من الشرائح لها
ظروفها ولها
ضوابطها وشروطها انت عندما تتحدث
عن يعني الرجال ليس كما تتحدث عن النساء
والاطفال في الظروف التي مرت ان تتحدث عن
بعض الناس الذين تحت الاحتياط
والتجنيد وهم
مستعدون ان يشاركوا في
العمليات الهجوميه والقتاليه
وال ضد شعبنا الفلسطيني وبالتالي كل شريحه
من الشرائح بلا شك لها ظروفها ولها شروطها
ام ما الذي طلبتم به مقابل عائله بيبرز
وال الاب الذي ما زال موجودا وما زال
حيا يعني احنا طلبنا مقابل عائله بيبرس
التي قتلها الاحتلال ان
الاحتلال اعاد محرري صفقه شليط الى السجن
دون د تهمه ودون شيء اعادهم ظلما وعدوانا
قلنا ليفرج الاحتلال عن
هؤلاء مقابل جثامين هذه العائله التي
قتلها
الاحتلال وهذا ما لم يستجب له
الاحتلال نعم لم يستجب والاحتلال كان يخطط
لاستئناف العدوان ولم تكن له اذان ولا عقل
يسمع وكان يريد ان ان يكسب الوقت ويمهد
الطريق لاستئناف العدوان والدمار لش شعب
الفلسطين طيب ماذا عن المجندات
عندما طالب الاحتلال بقائمه من المجندات
كيف تعاملتم مع
الموضوع هو الاحتلال بالمناسبه لم لم يطلب
ان يدخل في شريحه من الشرائح هو قال
للوسطاء نحن يعني مستعدون ان نتعاطى مع اي
شريحه من الشرائح احنا فضلنا ان ان نبدا
بشريحه كبار السن
اي من ال ممن من الرجال لانه هؤلاء لم لم
تصلهم الصفقه الماضيه موضوع المجندات غير
مطروح لم نطرحه لا نحن ولا هم لكن هم
بخباثه وبالتفاح على على على الوسطاء
سلمونا قائمه من الاسماء بالامس نصفها هم
مجندات وهم يدعون انهم ليسوا مجندين وهم
كاذبون طبعا واحنا ابلغنا الوسطاء ان هذا
العدد الذي سلمنا الاحتلالي هم عدد مجند
دات تم اسرهم من قلب الميدان وبزهم
العسكري ويحملون سلاحهم وهذا ثمنه مختلف
كما كررت اكثر من مره بالتاكيد
بالتاكيد نعم ام طيب انتم تقول منفتحون
على التفاوض وعلى الاقتراحات هل انتم الان
تقدمون مقترحا
معينا احنا منفتحون في كل الاوقات لكن
عندما يعلو صوت المدافع على صوت العقل
لابد من كبح جماح العقل اولا والزامه ب
دوليا بان تكف مدافعه ليستيقظ عقله العقل
الصهيوني مغلق العقل الصهيوني شاره للدماء
العقل الصهيوني يريد تدمير الشعب
الفلسطيني وتحجير هذا ما يفكر فيه ولذلك
باعتقادي
اي الان في هذا الظروف بعد استئناف
العدوان ونحن شاهد اطفالنا يقتلون وشعبنا
يشرد ما الفائده من الحديث عن حتى
الانفتاح وحتى احنا قلنا من الاول نحن
منفتحون وجاهزون لكن في وقت هذا العدوان
بالتاكيد نحن لدينا الانفتاح والمرونه لكن
نريد وقف الان واجب الوقت هو وقف العدوان
والقتل على شعبنا الفلسطيني يعني لا عوده
يعني لا ادري ان
كنت فهمت ما ما تقصد يعني لا عوده الى هدن
مؤقته وقف اطلاق نار يعقبه التفاوض
والتبادل من
جديد لا لا انا لم اقصد ذلك احنا في ملف
المدنيين جاهزون ان نبدا في هدنه جديده
نحن جاهزون الان ان نبدا في هدنه لتبادل
كبار السن
ا بشروط بشروط محدده نحن جاهزون وليس اح
نحن نتكلم عن تحديدا
عن العسكر والجنود ومن هم تح تحت الاحتياط
وتحت ندهه الاحتلال هذا المقول و هذا لابد
ان يكون يتوافق ويترافق مع وقف اطلاق
النار الشامل حتى ننهي هذا الملف لانه له
تعقيدات كثيره وله بالتاكيد شروط وضوابط
مختلفه اما في الشق المدني نحن جاهزون ل
الدخول والانفتاح في اي هدنه جديده
انسانيه لننهي ملف المدنيين وهذا ما كنت
سالتك عنه ان كان لديكم مقترح محدد بما ان
الرجال مختلفون اي كثمان عن النساء بطبيعه
الحال ان كان لديكم مقترح محدد الان يمكن
البناء عليه من اجل العوده الى الهدنه بما
ان لا لا يزال لدى حماس مدنيون اسرائيليون
محتجزون انا قلت استاذ حسن من بدايه
المقابله قلت نحن عرضنا الحديث عن كبار
السن ونحن جاهزون الان نتعامل مع هذا ال
مع هذه الشريحه لكن الاحتلال هو الذي رفض
ان يتعاطى اذا كان الاحتلال جاهز ان
يتعاطى مع هذه الشريحه فنحن جاهزون
بالتاكيد ام طيب الان متوقفه المفاوضات ام
مستمره تعلم انه الاتصالات بيننا وبنا لا
لا اتصال مباشر مع الاحتلال لكن الوسطاء
بلا شك لا يوجد شيء اسمه متوقف احنا الان
لا حديث حول هدن جديده الان اللي يعني هل
هذه الساعات لانه احنا احنا لعند الساعه
الثامنه صباحا بتوقيت فلسطين الساعه
التاسعه بتوقيت الدوحه كنا على تواصل مع
الوسطاء وهم يتواصلون مع الاحتلال عندما
بدا الاحتلال عدوانه وبدا يقصف المنازل
ويقتل الناس وبدا الشهداء بالعشرات اي
انتهى الحديث عن عن هدن يعني لكننا نقول
نحن جاهزون في الاستئناف الحديث حول اي
هدنه تستهدف المدنيين ونحنا ما زلنا نطرح
ما كنا نطرحه بالامس جاهزون ان نمضي فيه
من الان ونستكمل طيب اذا انتقلنا الى
الجانب الميداني الان الهدنه انتهت
العمليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه استؤنفت
والانظار نحو الجنوب كيف ستتعامل مع هذا
الملف الملف الميداني تحديدا اذا ما تركز
على مناطق جنوب قطاع
غزه يعني د ان يتحدث
بنفسه المقاومه
الفلسطينيه
ظهرت اخلاقيات وبراعتها وقوتها بما تملك
من قدرات طبعا ليست متكافئه مع العدو لكن
بالصبر والصمود والاقدام
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
والبسالة الدمار الذي احدثه دمار شام لكن
بالمقابل تكبد العدو خسائر وباعتقادي ان
المقاومه قادره يعني على تلقين العدو
ودروسا جديده وتكبيده خسائر عديده
باعتقادي ستكون اكبر مما وجده اي في
الشمال وبالمناسبه استاذ حسن العدوان لا
لا يقتصر على الشمال دون الجنوب او الجنوب
من الشمال الاحتلال اليوم قال عدوانه من
رفح حتى بيت حنون قصف بيوت على رؤوس
اصحابها في الشمال وفي مدينه غزه وفي
الوسطى وفي رفح وفي خانيونس لم تسلم منطقه
من المناطق وبالتالي الاحتلال بطياره انه
يقصف والمقاومه بامكانات سترد على هذا
القصف والمقاومه اي ستتعامل مع هذا العدو
الصهيوني المتواجد على الارض بكل بساله
وبكل قوه ولن تتراجع باذن الله طيب انتم
في حركه حماس ماذا تقراون ميدانيا اهداف
الاحتلال وهو الذي توغل في شمال قطاع غزه
كما كما هو معروف اهداف اذا صح تعبير
المرحله الثانيه من
اي هذه العمليات
العسكريه انا باعتقادي الهدف الاول عند
الاحتلال هو القتل ومزيد من القتل والدمار
ومزيد من الدمار لانه فشل حتى الان في
تحقيق ما يريد
من تهجير شعبنا والقضاء على مقاومتنا وغير
ذلك لكنه نجح نجاحا واضحا في تدمير
المنشات والبنيان وقتل اكبر قدر ممكن وجرح
من ابناء شعبنا باعتقادي ان الهدف المباشر
عند الاحتلال وليسمع القاسي والداني الهدف
المباشر عند الاحتلال هو التهجير الان
الاحتلال الصهيوني عينه على تهجير شعبنا
الفلسطيني من قطاع غزه الى سيناء
ورغم تقديرنا العالي لموقف الاخوه
والاشقاء في مصر وغيرهم لكننا نحذر من
سلوك الاحتلال في اي لحظه من اللحظات
بالدفع تحت وطا النيران والقتل والدمار ان
يدفع بجزء من ابناء شعبنا الى سيناء تعت
هذا الامر ولذلك نحن نعتقد انه هذا هو من
اكبر المخاطر ويمكن من اهم الاهداف التي
عين العدو عليها الان هو تهجير شعب
فلسطيني من الشمال الى الجنوب ثم من
الجنوب الى الشمال انت تتحدث اليوم عن ما
يقرب من مليون ونصف الى مليون و800 انسان
متواجدين في منطقه الجنوب يعني بمعنى انه
الان ضعف العدد اللي كان موجود الان في
فلا لا المستشفيات تتسع ولا البيوت تتسع
ولا الاغاثات تتسع اين اين سيذهبون هؤلاء
مع قله الغذاء والطعام والدواء و والشتاء
وغير ذلك اللي انا اعتقد انه المرحله
القادمه التي سينفذها الاحتلال بكل
خبث اللي هو الدفع باتجاه شعبنا الفلسطيني
خارج الحدود الفلسطينيه نحو مصر لكن انا
اقول ستبوء هذه المحاوله بالفشل بسببين او
بثلاث اسبب السبب الاول صمود شعبنا
واستبسال في البقاء على الارضه صمود
المقاومه وبسالته وقدرتها على رد العدوان
ثالثا الموقف المصري الاصيل الوطني
العروبي الانساني الذي يرفض تهجير شعبنا
الفلسطيني بكل الوسائل
هذا يحتاج الى ادوا عمل والى اليات ضغط
على هذا الاحتلال ليكف عن عن عن هذه
السياسه نحن نسمع كلاما من الاسره الدوليه
ومع المجتمع الدولي ومع الامريكان لا
لتهجير الشعب الفلسطيني العدو الصهيوني
الان يمارس سياسه التهجير فلم فنحن نستغرب
ونسته جن صمت وسكوت العالم وكان العالم
يقف مردوع خائفا من ان يردع هذا الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي مع ان دم وخرابه سيطال الجميع
في المنطقه وخارج المنطقه كيف فهمتم
الموقف الامريكي
تحديدا تصريحات انتوني بلينكن بعد لقائه
المسؤولين الاسرائيليين
بالامس تصريحات الاداره
الامريكيه الخارجيه وغير ذلك
تتلون وتغير في
الكلمات فينها الناس ان ان الموقف اختلف
الكلمات اختلفت والتعبيرات اختلفت لكنهم
يحموا العدو الصهيوني ويدفعونه باتجاه
استمرار العدوان والقتل لكن كيف تقتله لا
تقتله بقذيفه اقتله
برصاصه لا تدمر البيت ولكن اهدم اهدم نصف
البيت هذه هي السياسه الامريكيه نحن لا
نريد ان يفعل في الجنوب كما يفعل في
الشمال كيف يعني هو الان يفعل في الجنوب
ما فعله في الشمال ولذلك الاداره الا
امريكيه تلون من خطابها وتلين من الخطاب
والكلمات لكن الموقف واضح الاداره
الامريكيه ما زالت شريكه في العدوان
والقتل على الشعب الفلسطيني الاداره
الامريكيه هي جنبا الى جمع العدو تحميه في
في المجتمع الدولي وتحميه بالقرار وتمده
بالمال والسلاح والعتاد وتمده ايضا
بالاستمرار ولذلك الامريكان للاسف ما
زالوا شركاء في دمنا شر شركاء في قتلنا
شركاء يدفعون الاحتلال في التته العسكريه
المجرمه القاتله والا الامري امريكا قادر
على ان توقف العدوان في اي لحظه قادر على
ان توقف استهداف شعبنا الفلسطيني قادر على
وقف تهجير الشعب الفلسطيني هل يعقل ان كل
الاسره الدوليه غير قادره على الزام
الاحتلال الصهيوني بايصال الاغاثه والمواد
اللازمه حتى في الحروب لمن تحت القصف
والدمار للاسف الشديد هذا تواطؤ وشراكه من
الامريكان مع العدو الصهيوني شكرا لك
الدكتور خليل الحيه نائب رئيس حركه حماس
في غزه ومسؤول مكتب العلاقات العربيه
والاسلاميه في
الحركه